vamos a ver el reloj y observemos que
ahora está marcando el reloj tiene dos
manecillas la manecilla corta marca las
horas déjame anotarlo marca las horas
mientras que la manecilla larga está que
tenemos aquí va a marcar los minutos
así que empecemos con las horas que es
esta manecilla que tengo aquí pero antes
de encontrar las horas
quiero que observes que nuestro reloj no
está etiquetado
así que primero vamos a etiquetar las
horas bien aquí en la parte de arriba
tenemos siempre las 12 horas aquí vamos
a tener las 12 horas
allí es donde comienza nuestro reloj y
como las horas son estos cuadros grandes
que tenemos como marcas estas de aquí
entonces cuando pasamos a la siguiente
marca grande vamos a tener la una
después las dos
después las 3
después las cuatro por acá vamos a tener
las 5 las 67
10 11 y después observa que regresamos a
las 12 a las 12 en punto así que es
momento de regresar y observar nuestra
manecilla que indica las horas que es
justo
esta manecilla que tenemos aquí y bueno
si la observas bien te vas a dar cuenta
que está ligeramente pasando las 10 pero
no ha llegado a las 11 esto significa
que nuestra ahora está pasando las 10 en
punto tal vez las 10 05 o tal vez las
diez y media o tal vez otra hora pero no
hemos llegado a las 11 así que ya
estamos seguros que podemos poner en las
horas
número 10 son las 10 pero ahora vamos a
aplicarnos en los minutos y para eso
vamos a fijarnos en la manecilla de 2
minutos que se observa es esta que
tenemos aquí esta es la manecilla de dos
minutos que están marcando justo aquí
nos da esta marca de aquí y los minutos
son más pequeños es por eso que usamos
estas pequeñas marcas en el reloj los
minutos también empiezan acá arriba por
lo tanto cuando la manecilla está justo
en el número 12 serían las 10 en punto y
si se mueve un minuto justo aquí
tendríamos las 10 con un minuto o un
minuto después de las 10 y si se mueve
un minuto más tendríamos las diez con
dos las diez con tres las 10.4 y
tendríamos las diez con cinco entonces
aquí serían cinco minutos después
10 y después podemos seguir
sucesivamente las 10 con 6 10 puntos 7
10 con 8 10 con 9 10 con 10
aquí tenemos 10 minutos después de las
10 y aquí observamos seguramente ya
estás viendo un patrón recuerda que en
un principio teníamos las 1000 las 10 en
punto y después aquí en el 1
tenemos las 1005 y después aquí en el 2
tenemos las 10 con 10 entonces aquí en
el 3 tendríamos las 10 con 15 porque
estamos contando de 55 cada vez que
encontramos una marca grande por lo
tanto si nos movemos un minuto más
después de las 10 con 15 van a ser las
10 con 16
aquí tenemos 16 minutos y entonces la
hora que está marcando este reloj son
las 10 horas
con 16 minutos o dicho de otra manera 16
minutos después de las 10 y esa es mi
respuesta correcta muy bien ahora vamos
a hacer otro así que vamos a quitar este
que ya resolvimos y traigamos este nuevo
ejercicio de aquí que ahora marca este
reloj bueno de nuevo empecemos con la
manecilla de la hora bien de nuevo
empecemos con nuestra manecilla de la
hora que es esta que tenemos aquí y
bueno podríamos empezar a etiquetar todo
nuestro reloj estas son las 12 horas
aquí es la unam aquí son las 2 y
podríamos seguir y seguir y seguir pero
nuestra manecilla que nos interesa está
justo aquí por lo tanto no necesitamos
etiquetar todo el reloj observa que
nuestra manecilla está entre la una y
las dos pero no hemos llegado a las dos
por lo tanto podemos decir que la hora
va a ser la un
la una y algo y ahora si vemos los
minutos podemos ver que es bastante
después de la una en punto hemos
recorrido todo esto hasta llegar a la
manecilla de los minutos que da esta
marca de aquí ahora si recuerdas estos
son cinco minutos después tendríamos
diez minutos aquí teníamos 15 minutos 20
25 30 35 40 y no podemos seguir hasta 45
porque eso sería pasarnos entonces
llegamos hasta 40 y de aquí vamos a
irnos de minuto en minuto de uno en uno
tenemos 41 42 43 44 y llegamos nuestra
manecilla de los minutos marca 44
minutos por lo tanto nuestra hora es 44
minutos después de la una ola 1